remember if you ever shop on amazon.com
uh the shopping you already plan to do
the money new money you already plan to
spend could support our show all you
have to do is stop by david pakman.com
slash amazon before you shop a bunch of
people buying season one of Westworld
the HBO program everybody who recommends
this show to me well obviously if the
recommending it's because they think
they're good ever it that it's good
everybody who mentions this show to me
says that it is absolutely extraordinary
I don't have HBO so I haven't been able
to watch it yet now that you can buy the
season though i do want to check it out
it seems amazing you know since we've
been doing this I I realize that I have
to be starting to take in more TV shows
and rightly so I something to say about
them because I'm just used to watching
these kind of new media platform right
and I typically don't even ever see
these but have you heard of Westworld
I've not okay we'll see now now we're in
trouble folks now we're in trouble and
I'm gonna go ahead and move on uh no
westworld yes I I know I have to check
it out uh and and thanks everybody who's
buying it through our amazon link most
expensive purchase this week through our
amazon link I've never heard about this
it's an eye care frameless monitor it's
apparently so high resolution that it's
good for eyesight or something like that
very expensive monitor of five or six
hundred bucks or something like that
most expensive purchase what does that
mean that's frameless means that the
frame around it is so thin it almost
looks like just an image like there's
not a thick monitor frame like this
monitor behind me even though the frame
is pretty thick right here uh it's it's
it's a barely visible barely visible as
I do that okay if you ever shop on
amazon.com david pakman.com slash amazon